okay so I went to bed last night
thinking everything was fine and woke up
to the DC EU in turmoil it was honestly
like that bitten community and it's one
of the wildest stories to hit the movie
and comic book community in the last 10
years I've accepted at this point that
if I'm gonna be a DC fan then I'm gonna
have a bad time and it looks like things
are over The Hollywood Reporter dropped
a bombshell last night and broke down
how gun is likely wiping the Slate clean
in order to start off the DCU with a
fresh start he's throwing the baby out
with the bathwater and by the looks of
it everything's getting shelled in order
to start off a new 10-year plan that
could be announced as early as next week
we have some updates that you won't get
in any of the videos as well due to some
Stars speaking out after what's just
happened so stick around until the end
and obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you drop a comment
and also hit the Thumbs Up And subscribe
to stay locked in for any updates that
we end up getting by the way I'm your
host Paul now let's get into the video
okay so over the last week things have
been looking a bit suspicious on Twitter
reports flew about that Black Adam was a
bomb and The Rock replied to this to
show that it actually made some money
for the company was a bit of a cope I'll
be honest but then they made money look
he can prove it a girl could also put
out a tweet talking about her getting
the Wonder Woman part just yesterday and
in hindsight I think we can kind of
guess what this was about knowing what
we now know it is possible that Godot
was putting out a post and ordered a
rally fans together and show how popular
she is as Wonder Woman in order to keep
her job this looks like one of those
tweets taken before disaster and I think
she clearly knew that something was up
it's possible that she got told
yesterday then put this out and then The
Hollywood Reporter found out which is
What's led to all this chaos the outlet
stated that Wonder Woman 3 is not moving
forward in its current Incarnation and
that it's dead in the water right now
like like like some suicide squad team
member sake but is it a weasel well get
up may come back but as we get into the
video I'll go through why this could not
even be likely if God is out then that
means no one is safe and yeah if you're
gonna be a DC fan you're gonna have a
bad time now to quote the reporter
sources say that Jenkins recently
submitted her treatment co-written with
Jeff Johns and that gun and saffron as
well as Warner Brothers picture
co-chairs and CEO Michael Deluca and
Pamela ADB broke the news to the
filmmaker telling her the project as it
stood did not fit in with the new plans
Jenkins directed and co-wrote the
previous two movies starring Gal Gadot
released in 2017 and 2020. now decision
has been made about next steps and while
costs are not a factor insiders say that
DC Studios will not have any of
abundance and so of abundance some
Financial restrictions the studio could
end up saving tens of millions of
dollars by not making the third
installment get out according to sources
was on track for a 20 million Payday for
Wonder Woman 3 while Jenkins would have
received 12 million dollars those
figures don't include any possible
back-end bonuses so two things going on
here the movie's gonna cost a shitload
like 32 million dollars before you've
even started filming and I don't think
the company thinks that there's enough
Goodwill around Jenkins in Gadot to make
this a Surefire ahead after Wonder Woman
1984. Jeff Johns has had an almost toxic
aura that surrounds him as well and it
makes sense that they wouldn't want
anything that's attached to him I think
the guy's written some great comic books
in the past but he's been absolutely
terrible at running things and he's
stuffed so much talent on both the comic
book and movie side that it's baffling
he was even part of Wonder Woman 3 in
the first place on top of this the
reporter also talks about how they're
likely shutting down Man of Steel too
Cavill was back yay but but now he's
apparently out again without being no
contracts signed and no plans at the
moment to integrate him further I think
out of all the stories that this is the
biggest blow because it was so good good
seeing him come back for Black Adam we
finally had him back and they've just
been like nope you can't have anything
you're a [ __ ] scumbag and your
family's dead
he also just left the Witcher to
possibly focus more on being soups again
and if they drop the ball with him on
that then I think it's gonna be
difficult for me to really become
attached to anything else DC fans have
been through a lot recently and over the
last couple of years we've had the
snyderverse then the Snyder verse was
over then Cavill and Affleck out
hierarchy about to change then the
schneiderverse could be back then the
cul-de-sac comments again the hierarchy
about a change then them saying they're
gonna tell Multiverse stories now
another hierarchy change with the
discovery merger Batgirl canceled a new
10-year plan and cavali and Affleck back
and then [ __ ] off your family's [ __ ]
dead I think overall there's been so
many changes over the last year that
this needs to be the last one and if it
isn't then I can't see anyone coming
back it's difficult to get attached to
plans when we've seen countless times
before how much the plans can change and
I think this is also another reason why
they're wiping the sleigh clean they
just don't want to have this stuff
affecting their universe but it means
that the fans who love the old stuff are
gonna lose a lot too now along with
Cavill Jason Momoa could apparently be
out as Aquaman 2. according to the
reporter these characters are the cameo
in the flash the highly anticipated time
travel Adventure movie that's generally
Sun June 16th caval shot as part of the
cameo in September but sources say
there's a debate inside the studio as to
whether or not keep the Cameo and if its
inclusion promises something that the
studio would have no plans on delivering
a Warners Insider cautions that no plans
have been finalized and that flash
remains an unlocked picture now the
reporter then goes on to say a caval
situation is more than a little thorny
as the actor made a cameo Black Adam the
DC Centric movie released in October the
Monday after the movie opened Cavill
posted a video on Instagram where he
announced I wanted to make it official I
am back as Superman so that was a
[ __ ] lie now the reporter then went
on to stay well it might not be it might
be back we don't know what's happening
but the reporter then went on to State
Andy musketti who directed The Flash
even X expressed interest in sitting
behind the camera for something that
would have brought a tone similar to the
hopeful and heroic colors of the 1978
movie directed by Richard Donner in fact
the current leadership team at Warner
Brothers Pictures Michael Deluca and
Pamela Abdi did desire one more
go-around of the Snyder vs Heroes
possibly even having another Justice
League movie with those actors but that
was before gun and saffron began
formulating the new and still in flux
plan so we almost had another Justice
League with the Snyder vs actors but
nope can't have anything nice in this
world now from what I've been told about
Aquaman 2 they've also cut the Ben
Affleck cameo in that on top of these
other ones the movie was screened
earlier in the week to test audiences
and Affleck was missing from this
showing that he might be out as well
there's also the fact that Momoa talked
about how he was doing his dream project
as well and many people have speculated
that this could be Lobo so potentially
we'll see Aquaman 2 being the last
appearance of the character and then
he'll play Lobo in the DC you going
going forward now if they're removing
all these guys permanently then that
clearly has a knock-on effect I doubt
Shazam 2 is gonna get a sequel And the
reporter also says that Black Adam 2 is
unlikely they stated also unlikely is a
sequel to Black Adam I just said that
mate despite the hype surrounding the
movie of launching a new corner of DC a
lot of it led by star Dwayne Johnson the
movie has only grossed 385 million
worldwide and insiders at the studio say
the movie which costs more than 190
million to produce will be lucky to
break even even considering ancillary
Revenue even if the movie does seek out
a minimal profit any follow-ups inherent
rising cost damn the prospect of a
sequel Johnson Hub to carve out his own
piece of the DC pie but multiple sources
say his playing up of a returning caval
and his own involvement with DC may not
be endearing him to New Management
Johnson and Cavill are both managed by
Danny Garcia who's also Johnson's
producing partner the perception of Adam
turning a profit or not is is
conflagrating I don't know if that's
weird now being waged in public with
Johnson tweeting the movie with net over
50 million dollars after a variety story
said the movie would lose 50 million
dollars theatrically now the rock
actually posted a tweet this morning
responding to someone saying they can't
wait to see what's next he basically
said it's all nice and no it's sounding
Doom and Gloom at the moment I really
don't think that gun and saffron have
anything completely nailed down this
kinda seems like the Death Rows of the
dceu and those who still want to be
involved are throwing out their chords
to fans alongside the reports to show
their his support the Articles says part
of the plan could entail a truly fresh
start and having no baggage from
previous regimes as they said about
resetting how DC movies and shows are
made that however does not take into
account the possible success of movies
such as Shazam Fury of the Gods on which
saffron as a producer and Blue Beetle
will that plan include forging ahead
without actors who inhabit those
characters and will cast them even if
those movies prove to be box office hits
now at the end of the day you know no
matter what this report says there are
going to be two things that factor into
what gets kept and what doesn't the
first is whether it can bring in a
profit or not SAS lab has been ruthless
when cutting films and bakkill with
shelter attacks right off so he may want
to do the same thing with the entire
dceu if it's not going to make money
then there's a chance that things can go
and in the case of Black Adam and Wonder
Woman 3 I can see why they're not
banking on those being Sure Fire Hits I
would love to see Superman vs Black Adam
but the box office probably has the
executive spooked and they genuinely
don't know what to do the other thing
holding it back is like we said the fact
that the dceu has been through so many
different plan changes and visions and
it's a complete mess at the moment guns
seems to want to fire a gunfire and nuke
the entire locked because he knows that
it's probably a losing battle and that
every single movie that comes out will
deal with some form of backlash whether
it's from the people who want the Snyder
verse back or people who don't like the
new directions there will be some form
of controversy so I can see why they've
just decided to scrap the entire thing
and move away from the bad taste that's
in a lot of people's mouths personally
I'd love to see this manifest restored
but you know reading reports like this
I'm not exactly sitting there going
there's hope but you're telling me
there's a chance there is hope every so
often but maybe guns just like Nat's
done focus on this rather than having
people run while the theories and
pointing out how it could be coming back
now Gunn has an attachment to the old
slate too with Peacemaker and Margot
Robbie's Harley Quinn being tied to that
which is of course tied to the DC EU
there's also Amanda Waller as well and
he may even end up ditching his own
things like Peacemaker in order to clear
this slate man could be doing his own
Amanda Waller taking out his team if
they don't fit in with the plan I think
it's bad for Optics if he cancels the
other stuff but not his own and yeah
it's just wild how much this shake-up
entails however he could end up keeping
things in place and after being like
well that stuff still happened but
there's a new universe with certain
actors that I want to use going forward
now I don't think that the Reeves first
will be affected by this and that they
can still do Batman 2 and Joker too one
part that the gun saffron agenda seems
likely not to touch at least for now is
the Matt Reeves Batman Universe in which
Robert Pattinson does the cow of the
cake Crusader Reeves is writing the
sequel to The Batman which opened on
March 4th the filmmaker is also
overseeing the launch of two Batman
series at spin out of his movie
including the penguin don't know why I
read it like that no Joker and Batman
they did really well and were widely
accepted by the fandom because they
weren't attached to the DC EU
potentially and they were also good
movies obviously potentially Gunners
seen that and realized that that's
through to take but as of yet I don't
think anyone knows for definite and
that's the point I want to hammer home
even stuff like Wonder Woman 3 has been
rejected because it doesn't fit into the
upcoming plans but there is the
potential that they can rework it and
get it in line with that or I can could
just be completely killing myself as per
usual and holding on to this hope which
gun definitely doesn't seem to want us
to do this could be the biggest call
since the suicide squad and I genuinely
think it's impossible to say right now
exactly what's happening they obviously
haven't locked down the plan yet they're
just kind of been like uh let's tweak
things see what works and yeah if it
doesn't fit in it's gonna go even the
actors don't seem to know for definite
and with shocks like this constantly
coming out the blue it's impossible to
predict what's coming around the corner
galgarot said she can't wait to share
what's next so there is hope that it's
not all scrapped the story definitely
hasn't finished up and there could even
be some things dropping after this video
that debunks it and clears stuff up the
hierarchy has changed but whether it's
for the better or worse we just don't
know now if they do drop a big plan this
month that scraps all the snyderverse
actors and upcoming Universe plans then
I think it's gonna be so difficult to
market the upcoming DCU films their
lineup include Shazam The Flash and also
Aquaman 2 the latter lateral mod with
controversy because of Ezra Miller and
Amber Heard and if they're not even
building towards anything I can see
people skipping them completely it's a
bad idea to Market your comic book movie
by saying none of this matters and fans
have become accustomed to having to see
movies they wouldn't normally see
because there's an overarching storyline
let's be real Captain Marvel wouldn't
have broke a billion if it wasn't
jumping off the back of infinity war and
going into end game I think a lot of
issues with the dceu lineup is the fact
that no one cares about these c-list
Heroes because no one cares about the
old rocking storyline due to their not
really being one now Grace Randolph has
been saying this for weeks now and even
after Cavill popped up in Black Adam she
said things weren't locked in the video
talks about a lot of things that I
recommend you check out and personally I
think they're probably going to end up
scrapping a lot of this sleigh in order
to just start afresh obviously backlash
is gonna come from this and there's
already things trending like hashtag
fire James Gunn alongside comments like
make sure you like and also subscribe
now how would I handle I know I know
you're wondering how this guy who makes
videos from his bedroom how would he
handle these multi-million dollar
projects this one's for you James Gunn
get that notepad out I know you're
watching as well now I would have the
flash set up a big multiversal event and
then do a final Justice League film with
as many characters as you can get
earlier we talked about the snyderverse
actors being back and I'm even
potentially wanting to make another
Justice League film and I think you know
that would be the final way to close
everything out have them go against
Darkseid or something crisis on infinite
Earthship for all I care and then just
end on that and then start again people
aren't gonna forget the last 10 years of
movies and I think it makes more sense
to close the book on the movie Universe
with a movie rather than it's just
getting reports coming out like the
dcu's over we kill the entire family we
kill the [ __ ] told you kill him I
told you I'd kill them all I wonder
Brothers aren't really making that much
money at the moment so whether they'd
even invest in something like that
remain means to be seen think a big
reason Wonder Woman 3 was scrapped was
because the money they'd have to pay out
and if it didn't turn a profit it's
another further L to them so let's hope
we get something that's still to you
know give these guys a send off they've
been doing it 10 years and they've been
messed around so much that I just want
to say something that closes the book if
it is going to be closed I just kind of
feel bad for the fans and actors and
they've stuck with this universe and
Cavill even dropped out of The Witcher
season 3 potentially to do this I know
there was some stuff about him being
unhappy with the scripts and how it
wasn't really like the books but I think
of the Superman thing would have
definitely swayed him too so yeah just a
big overhaul by the sounds of it and I'd
love to hear your casting ideas for what
you'd want to see going forward Grace
mentioned that people would love to see
Anya Taylor joyous Harley Quinn and I
think that would be pretty solid do you
think they should just use the Reeves
versus a launch pad do you think they
should start from scratch are you
heartbroken are you happy comment below
and let me know I don't know how I feel
right now I've talked through it all and
yet still don't know now just to let you
know we are in competition right now and
giving away three copies of House of the
Dragon season 1 on the 15th of December
all you have to do to be when the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the news repeat the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that to you then message me
on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out one of our videos linked
on screen right now lots of things to
talk about not as depressing as this so
yeah definitely go head over there right
after this by the way thanks for saying
through the video I've been Paul I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]